welcome to our next video about the
flames of elden ring today we're going
to go about this video a little
differently as this is more of a theory
video than a lore video since we're
talking about the god slaying black
flame
before we begin i want to preface this
there's not much information
about the god slaying black flame or
rather what we know of it is so simple
that it may actually just be that but
usually it never is so this video is
about 90 speculation
so much so that i don't call this video
a lore video but a theory also if you
haven't watched the flame of ruin video
you should watch that as it relates to
this video
as always though let us start with
answering the simple question of
what is the god slaying black flame
it is a fire infused with the power of
death and it is channeled from the god
slayer's sword this sword was carried by
the dusk-eyed queen in ancient times and
its power was gifted to her apostles and
followers
the black flames would entice those who
served the flames such as the fire monks
as it would appear as a familiar yet
gentler flame than that of the flame of
ruin it would be for that reason that
aemon the first firemonk to turn traitor
would become part of the godskin
apostles
that is pretty much what the god slaying
black flame is most of the mystery that
surrounds this flame is about the
godskin apostles themselves and the
gloam-eyed queen
but there are already a lot of analysis
and theories on who the gloam-eyed queen
is so i won't get into that and frankly
i have nothing to add as i have no idea
of who it might be
instead i'm going to focus more on the
flame itself do not know that from this
point forward it's pretty much all
speculation so what i wanted to
speculate on is the origin of the black
flames in my previous two videos we have
the origins of both the frenzy flame and
the flame of ruin but the simple origin
of the black flame
is that it came from the god slayer
sword and is imbued with the power of
destined death
but is that really just it
well yes kinda but i think it goes a
little deeper than that
we do have to understand more about the
godskin apostles though in order to
truly understand the god slaying black
flame the first thing to note is how old
the godskin apostles actually are you
see the god skin nobles who are the most
ancient apostles have been alive since
the time of the crucible which is the
earth tree in its primordial form let me
give a quick explanation of what the
crucible is in the ancient past the
crucible is an amalgamation of all life
within the lands between a real crucible
looks like this
and all life was basically the contents
of that crucible which was blended
together this means that beings were
born with aspects of various creatures
in the examples we have from talismans
and incantations humans could have wings
scales tails horns and many other
aspects kind of like what the god skin
nobles look like
and even the apostles to a certain
extent the crucible knights draw power
from the earth tree in this form
allowing them to create divine shapes of
humans of the past the ancient godskin
apostles are also like this but instead
of just drawing power from incantations
they simply still embody the very aspect
of the crucible they assimilated in
human physiology
now what does this have to do with the
black flame itself like we saw in the
picture of what an actual crucible is
you'll notice that well the crucible is
on fire or rather it's under extreme
heat in my previous video where i talked
about the flame of ruin remember that
the flame of ruin itself is anathema to
the earth tree meaning it is the thing
the earth tree hates the most or it is
the curse to the earth tree
why is that though well only the flame
of ruin can burn the earth tree and
return it to its primordial state as a
crucible
this got me thinking if all life was
blended together into the crucible of
the earth tree and mixtures of divine
creatures were able to be created what
if aspects that are primordial in nature
like lightning and flame are capable of
the same feat meaning the reason we have
a lot of different flames or even
different lightning in the game is
because its power can be blended
together with other powers what if in
the ancient past the greater will took
the crucible created their version of
life in the lands between
but they may have neglected the flames
that could bring about its destruction
this could even be the mistake that the
three fingers mentioned during the quest
with hayeta
the flames didn't just represent
destruction but also curses ruination
and the like as such the flames were
taken by different factions within the
lands between the fel god took the flame
of ruin and created the cauldron
and from those flames the glomide queen
took destined death and created the
black flame the three fingers created
the frenzied flame
i know this is such a huge leap and like
i said it's 100 just a theory but hear
me out in elden ring there are a lot of
different flames and they all have
subtle differences most notably in color
but also effects and origin the normal
flames without any special properties
look like this
this is a crucible incantation meaning
it draws from primordial life dragonfire
also looks like this
the flame of ruin gets a more red orange
hue to it and all flames associated with
the giant's flame have this color the
flame of ruin is there for the
destruction of the earth tree it is what
would turn the earth tree back into a
crucible then we have the frenzied flame
which is more yellow in color we also
know from the fingerprint shield that
before it was the frenzied flame it was
referred to as the frenzy and it was
from interpretations of words that the
seeds of frenzy sprouted now i'll be
honest this one is a bit more open to
interpretation as well but what if
eventually the frenzy combined with the
flame in order to become the frenzied
flame just like how the aspect of the
crucible can combine with any life there
is also the ghost flame which is mostly
white and a little bit of black this was
flame used by the death birds and was
present even before the earth tree
meaning this already existed
during the crucible
this flame was used to burn death this
is probably the form of true death
before the time of the earth tree
the difference with this though is that
it's cold flame it inflicts frost
instead of doing fire damage
this in my theory is the first
combination of the power of death and
normal flame
lastly the black flame which was capable
of slaying gods which may be a
combination of destined death and the
flame of ruin but if i'm being honest i
think it's a combination of ghost flame
and the flame of roman hence the color
the gods were divine beings and the
current demigods and god that we know of
are strongly tied to the earth tree this
means that maybe while their power was
given to them by the greater will it was
formed from the power of the crucible
i believe they were impervious to normal
death and it takes the full power of the
rune of death to truly kill them as seen
with the hollow brand of death between
godwin and ronnie and you had to
intricately carve the hollow brand
within their body to truly slay them or
probably just use
the black blade of malakath which is
basically the rune of death so it is a
herculean task in order to truly slay a
demigod and probably much more for a
true god but there is something else
that can harm the earth tree and return
it to its original form
as the crucible and that's the flame of
ruin
it was such a danger that marika herself
had to slay the fel god who had it and
so i believe that the black flame
wielded a combination of the flame of
ruin and destined death or maybe even
the ghost flame its frost aspect was
removed due to its combination with the
rune of flame but the black flame wasn't
so hot because of the frost aspect that
weapons like the godskin peeler didn't
do fire damage even though it is capable
of channeling the black flames but the
god slayer sword which channels its full
power does do fire damage
this power
was what the gloam-eyed queen and the
godskins used in order to slay gods
these gods might be the ones in the
walking mausoleums they supposedly house
soulless demigods those demigods may
have been slain by the god-skinned
apostles but that's that's a theory for
another time but when malaketh sealed
the rune of death which by the way it is
never stated anywhere that he sealed the
rune of death by defeating the
gloam-eyed queen this means that he
could have sealed the rune of death long
after he defeated the gloam-eyed queen
or even before this basically means that
the glow might queen may or may not have
had the rune of death long ago
but that's i am not too sure about that
so when malika sealed the rune of death
the true power of the god sling black
flame was also sealed it lost its death
aspect with it
but it still worked as a flame
we can see further evidence of this by
just looking at the incantations
themselves all of the black flame
incantations have similar incantations
to that of the giant's flames
they both have fireballs they both have
sweeping flames they both have flames
that erupt from the ground
even their incantation effect
description is basically the same this
may also be why some fire monks betray
the flame of ruin because they can see a
similar beauty of the flame within the
god slaying black flames
this act of combining incantation
properties though may be blasphemous as
we can see with reichard's rancor it
seems like a combination of death magic
and flame magic this is also basically
the same principle behind the taker's
flame where it combines the serpent's
ability to devour and the flames ability
to burn and do damage thus giving you a
life stealing kind of flame in the
taker's flame and lastly if you believe
the theory that melina might be the
gloam eye queen then it makes sense why
she is also the kindling maiden she has
mastery in both the flame of ruin as
well as destined death but once destin
death was sealed she basically only
carried the power of the flame and when
destined death was unbound and the flame
of ruin was used up to burn the earth
tree she returned to becoming the
gloam-eyed queen and her other eye this
time was closed i know it's a bit of a
stretch but i wanted to try my hand in
theorizing as well
but what do you guys think though is
there a shred of truth to what i'm
saying or is the three fingers invading
my mind and causing me some madness let
me know what you guys think in the
comments down below and if you made it
this far thank you for entertaining this
crack theory this is basically an
experiment if i can make sense of
anything that is going on behind the
scenes but yeah thank you so much for
watching